all right so let's have a listen here to
how much money should a guy make per
year as uh
you know positioned by these checks
let's hit play here oh they look dumb
um it depends where they live I mean if
I'm like dating them it'd be nice if
they were at least making a hundred
thousand
[Music]
um
I have no I mean like 100 Grand is kind
of reasonable like that's that's not
that hard to make really like a million
that's middle class income in major
cities now like two million dollars
this chick this chick thinks that she's
deservative a guy that that like makes
two million dollars a year I don't know
any dude that makes that kind of cash
that would pick a [ __ ] basic looking
chick like this right
look at her face okay we're at ASU you
know so you're not gonna find him here
like fully like adult someone that you
you would consider wanting to be with
the rest of your life 300 okay three
figures
okay so why is that
this [ __ ] kills me man I'll grab that
check if that's your expectation yeah
she'll be real happy it's a very low bar
I mean some dude living on the corner of
the street with a [ __ ] rat as a pet
could could probably [ __ ] feel that
my car console has got that and change
yeah
it's like a lot of money that I that
like Drop accidentally in the course of
a year right I keep that in my emergency
bag for when the building starts shaking
I'm like all right if this Falls over I
need to be able to get to an airport and
get the hell out of here yeah I need to
get 999 dollars real quick
what no that's clueless like it's like
it's five hundred thousand dollars a
year a lot like utterly Clueless
500 is
[Music]
yeah I mean it depends okay uh a lot
we're expensive yeah
this this trick here the I'm just gonna
put my finger this chick here thinks
she's expensive
looking like that
Mills
Mills [ __ ] okay I don't really care I
think I mean I like when guys like pay
for dates and stuff so if a guy made 30k
a year is that something you're okay
with yeah I think that would be great
skater chick there you go boys just go
for the skater chick looks like the RC
chicks too or down yes looks like she's
got a nice set too decently your husband
oh [ __ ] husband
yeah I think that would be fine if it
was my husband I'd be in love with him I
wouldn't really say I would hope yeah
that's what they say again guys watch
what women do now here we go
I mean as long as they treat me
respectfully minimum six figures no
matter what the situation is we have an
expensive lifestyle yeah
this trick here
I don't know moth Jared like you guys
are in the dating Market would you grab
an expensive lifestyle she wouldn't be
one to take out in public but to be
honest if it's like Wednesday night and
she agrees to come straight to the house
and just chill but yeah
these are going to be the same girls
that are be saying that they don't need
a man in five years yeah these are just
basic chicks these are chicks you
smashed through yeah so what we'll do is
we'll is we'll go to the female delusion
calculator or go to I got standards bro
and you know we'll see what that looks
like I think these are all at Arizona
State if I'm not mistaken so it's
definitely in the states
no I mean I totally understand we got to
get good skin care routine you know the
whole whole nine yards
120k 80
like 120
[Music]
I would say like 80 to 150.
this trick demands 80 to 150.
that's about the best she's ever gonna
look like you know I think women are in
their Prime it's not really you know
disputed in their very early 20s over
100k once you get to a certain age like
I don't know I'm also kind of like gold
digger so no um I'm planning on just
like supporting myself
um sure you are sweetheart so I don't
really plan on being supported by the
person that I'm dating what is the
lowest you would go so the next question
that she should be asked then is how
much money you know do you expect to
make in your job and then ask her if she
would date a guy or marry a guy that
makes less money than that right like
that's the correct way to follow up on
that rich someone I I think I think
you're missing the whole point here well
she's literally asking them is how much
would it take to make you a prostitute
for a decade
yeah that's literally it they should
turn them around and go well we've
established that fact now we're just
haggling over the price yeah
[Music]
um
500 000.
I could have a like a nice like subtle
life with like a 200 000 a year like
normal yeah what's the lowest though
that you would go for
uh I don't think money is talking uh
maybe like a
uh it has to be you just said one or two
mil would you be down for 80.
okay okay that's fair enough
she's honest I'm sticking with a hundred
thousand he's gotta you know yeah I I
would agree a hundred thousand
preferably I mean as long as they're
stable like have a good job
like a car and a house I I don't think
like money cares like it's not that high
on my list I'd say well I would probably
say the lowest I could would consider
going is 65 000 a year because then like
if they're young they have room for
improvement and they can get promotions
and work their way up would you be
comfortable with making more money than
your guy or no
um probably not no I don't want him to
rely on me oh gee we've ever heard that
before
people go insane in the comments no oh
it's not that way yeah welcome to the
comments after this but like we know
women date across and up on the
socioeconomic scale right here it's like
they're all saying I need a rich guy but
I'm also not going to date a guy that
makes less than me too like even when
they're coming close to 80 100 stuff and
I also don't need a man yeah I don't
need a man I'm gonna support myself yeah
they should just put price tags they're
on their necks yeah why not you know
this is what it'll cost it's like you
know going to the store whenever you're
picking up uh produce or whatever money
then I don't think it really would
matter if you're both putting work in
the guy who's talking to told me women
shouldn't be working so no with a whole
family right you got like four dogs ten
kids didn't that chick say she wanted a
guy that makes half a million dollars a
year and then she's saying that some guy
told me that a woman shouldn't be
working so like what are you gonna do if
he's making half a million dollars
exactly because that's plenty of money
like even in New York City that's that's
that's very good money right so what
exactly are you gonna do you're gonna go
out to the flower shop and like make
bouquets for forty thousand dollars a
year or something like that and make
your contribution like I want to do my
share here's my you know [ __ ] you
know contribution to the pot just stay
home and raise the kids and take care of
the house like why is that complicated
guys I smelled dick and I gotta roll see
you later brother
no pun intended that was disgusting okay
well I'm expecting to make a lot of
down to be the breadwinner yeah no I
wouldn't mind if I was making more money
as long as they're making a lot I think
we both need to be rich and we can both
have a really nice lifestyle I mean do
you care about how he would make it did
I ever tell you guys about the story
about all the mortgage applications I've
gone through over the years
I used to do private mortgages a lot
right and I I don't know I've probably
seen something like 150 maybe 200
um mortgage applications and it always
shows the income of of Mr versus Mrs
whenever there's a couple because you
gotta you know you gotta vet the
borrower too for credit worthiness
and I think there was one that I saw the
entire time where she made more money
than he did the vast majority out of
every single one that I saw he always
made considerably more money than Mrs he
had like a higher paying riskier longer
hour type of job and she had some [ __ ]
like you know receptionist that
insurance brokerage or nail salon owner
or something like that
so all these women that are going on
about oh you know we should both make a
lot of money and you know bring a lot to
the table that's just not what I see in
the real world
but I've noticed in my career too like
when I came out of school I'm in like
marketing PR advertising at the
corporate level
um and when I came out of school it was
overly saturated with with women like
this but but about the time I started
hitting 30 they started falling off
pretty quickly and then the people that
weren't that good and now I'm kind of in
in an area where you don't really see a
lot of women in like upper management or
console uh consultative type roles
anymore and I've noticed that in a
variety of industries that it's
saturated with younger people junior
level associate level and then as you
get up there um it screens them out
pretty quick real estate job versus you
know a male stripper
I don't think so money's money
that's not just railing chicks on only
fans you'd be fine with that about that
one
[Music]
sorry the 80d is really wait what the
[ __ ] okay what would happen if you you
know started dating this guy and he told
you that you get a lot of money and
whatever and then you later found out he
was broke
I'd leave him he's a liar and he's broke
he has like no motivation to fix it or
he's like I've been selling feed picks
non-stop on my only fans and I'm I swear
to God I will be making 100K by the end
of the year I know someone that does
that probably like blackmail him maybe
proud of it yeah blackmail him great
women I just [ __ ] blackmailed my
husband
because dick pics
yeah I got to you babe really yeah okay
yeah bear down but the men here way
hotter and all the guys that are
[ __ ]
is that what you're doing you talking
[ __ ] no I'm just okay a guy named will
that's all
yeah if you will antique do you guys
care about how he makes his money you
know because if he's making good money
doesn't matter what he's doing
specifically to make that money
honestly kind of yeah
yeah
it doesn't matter
all right let's let's go to the female
delusion calculator I believe it's I got
standards bro that one's funny Rich I'm
curious though too to what degree is it
because a lot of colleges especially in
the US and Canada They Don't Really
educate students anymore I'm wondering
like do these chicks even know how much
money that is I doubt they said yeah I'm
like here's what here's what you need
realistically to get ahead in this major
metro area in this industry because I
don't remember them having that
conversation with me when I was in
college I had to kind of figure that out
once I got out in the work
they don't at all
um
all right so if you guys want to have a
laugh go to
igotstandardsbro.com and it's the female
delusion calculator
so I think these chicks are mostly in
their 20s so let's let's assume that a
25 year old is going to want like a
probably what 28 to 35 year old would be
their ideal age range
I mean women tend to date a little bit
older right like was that fair yeah I'd
say that's good that's right we'll leave
good Mary you want to exclude married
guys
yeah uh okay exclude married guys
um we'll just leave race out of the
picture and you know because they almost
always ask for a minimum of six foot on
dating apps let's give them six foot six
good obese oh yeah it would be six foots
and let's just say 100K so six figures
right so let's see what that gives us
this is all this could be attainable now
in most major cities yeah it's not it's
not
unreasonable but you're gonna find out
what the probability is so it's it's a
0.46 so less than half a percent of guys
in that age group meet their
requirements for husband stock that that
doesn't take into any consideration
attractiveness assets
uh you know like in influence
captivation you know whether or not
they're interesting or if they're boring
it doesn't take any of those things into
consideration that women will typically
disqualify guys up so just based on not
married any race at least six foot tall
not fat and earning six figures you're
talking point four six percent
which is funny because in my head that's
like oh that's just an average dude
because I hang out with guys that are
kind of higher level now I'm like okay
like that's kind of that's kind of a
baseline that's where you should strive
to I know between like the two
communities I think that's probably
based on like hey once you hit six
figures then come over to the top one
percent so for me I'm like oh that's
just an average dude just based on my
minor circle now right yeah it's just I
don't know this is like
this is the uh this is a world we live
in man you know as I say this is where
we're at right hey guys I really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out